gratuit on ne le verrait décerner pelle
ou minou tout d'abord je voudrais dire
que ce débat ici les politiques il et
pas juridique il est politique parce
qu'il aura un impact extrêmement lourd
sur notre économie européenne
ensuite je suis très heureuse de
l'unanimité ya une unanimité totale dans
notre hémicycle j'espère que la
commission et le conseil l'entendent et
en prendrons acte
nous considérons tous sauf quelques
banques nous soyons que évidemment la
chine n'est pas une économie de marché
et qu'à partir de ce moment là les
choses sont simples nous ne devons pas
lui donner le statut d'économie de
marché
ça n'est pas plus compliqué que cela et
j'espère que vous l'entendez et nous
devons en même temps agir dans quatre
directions 1 l'europe doit se doter
enfin d'instruments commerciaux fort
défensif ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
2 elle doit se doter enfin d'une
stratégie industrielle commune et d'une
stratégie d'investissement commune en
particulier dans tous les domaines
d'avenir
3 l'europe doit parler sur cette
question d'une seule voix il y aura
évidemment du chantage de la chine sous
les états membres je vous le dis restons
unis unis nous serons forts diviser
c'est l'europe qui perdra et enfin ce
débat c'est pas seulement un débat pour
les experts et les diplomates
c'est un débat pour tous les citoyens
européens et je souhaite donc que la
démocratie européenne se saisisse de
cette question je vous remercie
grazie on aurait volé en berbère ou
minutes plus tard il faut finir et
makoun au magistère